a single nursing home near Seattle is
connected to more than half of the u.s.
coronavirus deaths Jonathan Vigliotti is
in Kirkland Washington tracking the
effort in that state to prevent a wider
outbreak Jonathan what are officials
doing and good morning to Michelle the
hospital behind me one of the main
locations where patients sickened with
the virus have been taken for treatment
here in Washington State at least 21
deaths as you mentioned 16 of those
fatalities directly linked to the life
care nursing home in Kirkland which had
to actually wait a week for enough
testing kits as some of the most
vulnerable succumb to the virus that
facility says it still has six residents
and 70 staff members showing symptoms in
one case a person dying within 24 hours
of showing symptoms yesterday on Face
the Nation we heard from the former FDA
Commissioner Scott Gottlieb who said the
nation is now past the point of
containing his spread he warned of
drastic steps including closing
businesses take a listen we have to
implement broad mitigation strategies
the next two weeks are really going to
change the complexion in this country
we'll get through this but it's going to
be a hard period we're looking at two
months probably of difficulty and
governor jay Inslee also speaking on
Face the Nation yesterday saying his
state is also considering some of those
drastic steps including mandatory social
distancing to reduce large-scale
activities and gatherings Tony Jonathan
thank you very much